marvel's red guardian is essentially the
russian version of captain america
and this soviet agent has always been a
morally complicated character
so let's take a deep dive into the world
of russian superheroes
and discover the untold truth of red
guardian
the creation of lexi shostakov aka red
guardian or someone like him
was kind of inevitable the cold war was
a big part of 1960's marvel comic
storytelling
and having a soviet doppelganger was
practically required for the major
superheroes
the hulk fought the abomination a kgb
agent who'd been changed by gamma rays
into an
even bigger and uglier green monster
iron man faced the crimson dynamo a
soviet physicist who built his own suit
of super armor
spider-man even went up against what
seemed to be an exact
duplicate of himself but it turned out
to be a russian super agent better known
as the chameleon
interestingly steve rogers counterpart
first appeared not in a captain america
comic
but in avengers number 43. stranger
still
the first time cap and the team
encountered shoshkotov they weren't in
russia
instead they found shosuketov in china
where he was working with a chinese
agent named colonel ling
captain america immediately recognized
the red guardian as a copy of himself
which chozkitov acknowledged
instead of a shield this red guardian
had a detachable belt buckle that he
could throw his weapon and then recall
using magnets
it was a pretty silly 1960s gimmick but
the important thing was that having
something round to throw at his enemies
gave him that recognizable
captain america-esque aesthetic although
she wouldn't officially join the
avengers until a few years later the
black widow was with earth's
mightiest heroes when they first met the
red guardian by this time widow had
stopped being a kgb spy and she was a
close ally
and love interest of the avenger hawkeye
but as soon as she saw the red guardian
natasha knew
she recognized him but she couldn't
believe who he actually was
it turned out that the husband she'd
long thought was dead had been alive
all along alexi shostakov's death was
faked by the kgb so that he could be
secretly trained as the red guardian
even though he'd allowed his wife to
think he'd died he was embittered when
he learned she defected to the us
and was fraternizing with american
superheroes natasha remembered her
husband
as a great soviet pilot and war hero but
she was unprepared for the costumed
super brute he'd become it's easy to
imagine a version of the red guardian
who stuck around
and became one of captain america's top
villains he could have antagonized cap
again
and again with a different scheme each
time like a cold war equivalent of
captain america's original arch enemy
the nazi red skull
if stan lee had still been plotting the
avengers when he was introduced
that might have happened by 1967 however
a younger generation of writers was
beginning to take over at marvel
and red guardian co-creators roy thomas
took things in a different
direction
the red guardian wasn't a nice guy and
you couldn't call him a superhero
however he had a certain nobility to him
after all
how else could he be the first love of
someone like black widow
who ultimately turned out to be a hero
herself he also had a measure of respect
for captain america the hero who had
inspired his new costumed persona
so after running into the avengers in
china shosukatok pulled a pretty
impressive move
sacrificing himself for black widow and
captain america
the superheroes were about to escape
amid the complete destruction of a
chinese space but as they were getting
ready to go
colonel ling planned on shooting captain
america in the back and that's when
shosuketov made a split-second decision
to sacrifice his own life to save cap
natasha
and their allies the red guardian may
have been a supervillain but he died
like a hero the second red guardian who
first appeared in the defenders number
35
wore basically the same costume as the
first but was different in every other
way
first of all she was a woman a russian
neurosurgeon named dr tanya balinsky
secondly she wasn't a government
operative in fact she used her costumed
identity to protect
dissidents within the ussr as well as
fighting crime that was a pretty
dangerous way to live so when dr strange
brought her to the united states to
perform delicate brain surgery
she decided to stick around as the red
guardian she became a member of the
defenders and a member of the american
superhero community
although she disagreed with the
oppressive soviet government tanya was
herself a communist which gave her a
different perspective on all
sorts of matters from the rest of the
defenders who were mostly
american capitalists plus one as
guardian valkyrie
and an atlantean prince during her time
with the defenders the red guardian was
targeted by a russian
agent who exposed tanya and himself to a
high dose of nuclear radiation which
gave them both superpowers but
it also made them highly radioactive for
a time she was under his complete mental
control thanks to his new powers but
ultimately
tanya helped the defenders defeat the
agent now known as the presence
unfortunately the level of radiation she
was giving off meant that the red
guardian had to isolate herself from
humanity to keep from killing
everyone around her in other words her
days as an active superhero were over
and she had to leave the defenders
she would return from time to time over
the years and eventually
she got her radiation under control and
operated under the name
starlight however she was never as
prominent a character as during her
initial run with the defenders
the third red guardian first appeared in
captain america number 352
named joseph petkas this guardian
represented a return to the original
concept of a soviet super agent
and direct counterpart to captain
america but by his introduction in 1989
relations between the united states and
the soviet union were much more civil
and the relationship between captain
america and the red guardian was
likewise there was tension and a bit of
mistrust between the two super soldiers
but they were
ultimately allies in fact the story that
introduced the new red guardian had him
taking cap on a walking tour of moscow
and then they fought a monster that
turned out to be the manifestation of
the sublimated powers of another group
of forgotten russian super beings
it was a very different sort of story
that perfectly represented the sometimes
strained piece that existed between two
of the world's superpowers
as the cold war drew to a close in a
certain sense the yosef petkis red
guardians split the difference between
aleksey schoskitov and tanya belinsky
like shoskatov petkis worked for the
soviet government and served as a mirror
to captain america right down to
carrying a shield of his own
instead of a flying belt buckle however
like belinsky he was a true hero of the
russian people not a brutish villain in
a superhero's clothes
when he and cap were strolling through
moscow in his first appearance the
guardian was cheered and greeted
affectionately by the public who
regarded him as a greater hero than his
american counterpart
he even lifted a little girl who asked
to fly like a superhero
and tossed the delighted child in the
air this was a time
even in the primary colored world of
superhero comics
when americans were by and large ready
to accept that
being a communist even being a soviet
didn't mean you were a bad person
and the character of joseph petkas
reflected that
on december 26 1991 the soviet union
collapsed after years of unrest and
loosening restrictions
with no more soviet government there
could be no more soviet operatives as
villains or conflicted heroes and comic
books set in the present
marvel comics with their 30-year legacy
of soviet supervillains
dealt with this by publishing a 1992
one-shot comic aptly titled soviet super
soldiers
this title told the story of how the
various costumed soviet characters in
the marvel universe
dealt with the collapse of the state
that had given so many of them their
powers and identities
joseph petkas remained of the red
guardian and he eventually
became part of a reformed super team
called the winter guard
which kept the peace in russia and
around the world in turbulent times he
eventually changed his name to the steel
guardian
and he gave his life in the line of duty
like the hero he'd always been
for twenty-four years of marvel comics
alexey shoskotov was regarded as the
first red guardian
at some point however it occurred to
somebody at marvel that both captain
america and the soviet union had both
existed for decades before 1967
so there was no reason not to have an
earlier version of the character
so 1991's namor the submariner annual
number one
introduced alexi lebedev the red
guardian of world war
ii naturally he was an ally of captain
america against the forces of nazi
germany but
after the war lebadev soon found himself
opposing his former allies
although his full story has yet to be
told he was said to have been killed by
his own government during the 1950s
revising the origin story of the aleksey
shoshkotov red guardian to be an attempt
to create a more loyal replacement for
lebedev
as the flagship superhero of russia the
red guardian often seems to be regarded
by marvel as more of a concept worth
keeping around
than a fondly remembered character and
thus there have been more recent
guardians who were never really
developed beyond a costume
krasnogranitsky the fifth red guardian
was introduced in maverick volume 2
number 10.
after appearing in three issues of that
book he was assassinated by
a kgb general the very next time he
showed up in captain america volume five
number one
the sixth red guardian first appeared in
hulk volume two number one
and the only real name he was ever given
was anton
a member of the winter guard he was by
all accounts kind of a jerk
and he also turned out to be an android
the seventh and most recent red guardian
was nikolai krillenko
a russian superman who was previously
known as vanguard
he first showed up under that name in
1978's iron man number
109 but he didn't take on the identity
of the red guardian until darkstar and
the winter guard number 3 in 2010
after anton the android red guardian got
his head
ripped off check out one of our newest
videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite marvel characters are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one